but a better copy but a better cop you  had it yeah I'm not I got it the hand  over the mouth was good I got it I'm  sorry I'm gonna get called black acting  school  I want you to try again and I want you  to try again  oh no telling the truth Maya you will be  some Ostia yose oh here we go  yeah yeah we look you looking yeah  looking we were you looking so you take  this lady baby one time know ya mean  know me and roll out I'll never get no  white baby baby and another nobody why  baby down swooped down grab the white  baby I got eagles right and when he  grabbed the right baby  everybody was like oh I'll take that  white man  if you guys bedazzled I got a kick-ass  bedazzled machine at the hotel we will  be here all night right now  cuz of Kevin Hart looking at Nunez's in  on it Olivia Munn's  laughter I'm sorry up canvases house  with the guy  you